qué sabemos de pensilvania
ubicado en la costa este / maryland de
nueva york y ohio pensilvania no es muy
grande en eeuu un poco más de 119 mil
kilómetros cuadrados los montes
apalaches lo cruzan sin embargo
pensilvania está densamente poblado más
de 12 millones de habitantes una
población mayoritariamente concentrada
en las grandes ciudades del estado como
filadelfia o pittsburgh pensilvania ha
sido durante mucho tiempo una tierra
industrial la extracción de hierro y
carbón de los apalaches hizo su riqueza
hasta los años 70 hoy el gas de esquisto
le ha dado nueva vida a este sector
aunque la tasa de desempleo es una de
las más altas del país conocido como el
estado clave pensilvania hace honor a su
nombre es un territorio decisivo en cada
elección están en juego 20 votos del
colegio electoral y los resultados
siguen siendo ajustados en cuestión una
división de su población votantes
demócratas cerca de filadelfia y
republicanos cerca del estado de ohio
desde 1992 el estado ha votado por el
candidato demócrata en 2016 trump había
ganado por un corto margen poco más de
40 mil votos